a única coisa que eu tenho raiva no
calor é que tudo que o cara faz no calor
é com raiva a prestar atenção o cara
fala assim irmão bora tomar um sorvete
olha mano essa desgraça Eu só pego
informação para você na rua se você
tiver no frio é outra coisa meu amigo
Você sabe onde fica a Rua das Oliveiras
hã sim claro claro eu quero amigo Claro
claro ficaria honrado em acompanhar mas
infelizmente Terei que buscar meus
filhos nas escolas né infelizmente não
felizmente né fiquei feliz é aquele que
tem crianças que tem filhos Ah no calor
tá ok e tal você pode é saber onde é a
Rua você não diz você sabe dizer onde é
que é a rua das Oliveiras Ô rapaz eu não
moro aqui não eu cheguei agora ó Cheguei
agora aqui nem conheço nada 20 anos que
ele mora ali